hey this is the Special Rapporteur for
geek culture we are here live at the
Galen Center in downtown LA for some
more news on the next-generation console
from Microsoft we've been calling it
Scorpio up to now but today we're going
to learn the true name the price the
games at the launch and of course
they're going to unleash the actual
console from under the hood imma take a
first look at what the console looks
like I'm super excited as you can see
everything and everyone here is bathed
in green and to get into this very
exclusive media presser you had to get
one of these Xbox chips real plastic
transparent awesome swag collectible
swag so sit back take a ride for the
next generation console
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone this is Z on the set of the
xbox media presser 2017 shots have been
fired in the console war starting with
Microsoft what did you think of all
those announcement well first off my do
I want to give a big shout out to keep
coaches hey hey in a way you do shot
fire cuz that's every son that I started
in the gaming industry you still have
you got a look at the camera and you
have like this one so three shots fired
that's how you got to do it I think you
pop boom now that was real yes now I'm
gonna say I'm a Brooklyn you've got to
be real so they tell me I'm explaining
on to you business absolutely
absolutely the best Xbox conference that
I've ever stock has been a part of I've
been going to e3 for 10 years every
Greenberg is a great friend of mine
that's my dude Major Nelson say even
though I stood before you were any game
of your choosing you know you know what
it is all right yo Phil Spencer I love
you you're doing a like incredible job
shout the diametric but what you're
doing and what you did and what y'all
brought together it's classic this is
amazing anthem anthem this is the anthem
yo it's just mind-blowing I really
appreciate what they're doing and I feel
like they going back to the community
like how do you deal with the 360 this
is unbelievable take it away this now um
you're from the FCC what is your name
good sir my name is Reginald Butler but
I go by the name of killer instinct
because it's not very nice every game
from yes so uh yeah now speaking of
fighting games just like killer instinct
which is going to have some enhancements
on that backwards-compatibility they
drop the bombshell with that Dragon Ball
Z fighters Oh tell me about that Dragon
Ball Z fighters Arc System Works a a
marriage made in heaven you're gonna get
the belt I've never seen nothing like it
before I screams to the top of my lungs
the characters look larger than I've
ever presented in the television show oh
hold on what yeah
it'll be easy on the Cartoon Network
listen listen listen in 4k or xbox 1x
listen yeah that'll be the game that
seems children to be a game bag that's
already gained
another thing I want to say is I love
the variety the variety of all the games
that they showed is great and it's also
I'm very impressed see that they allow
life is strange too they get shown on
their stage that's one of my favorite
games don't nod to lose I think that's
incredible so to me I really feel like
they're on the right track and they
prove that $4.99 is worth the price give
me that $4.99 price that's ok with you
I'll tell you I'll tell you guys like
this I would skeptical skeptical you
know seem to come with another 49 price
point but I would say this they have
delivered I'm buying one if you don't
get one I don't know what to tell you
but they have delivered on everything
they say look Anthem is market price of
admission alone pays down back hey ok I
gotta ask you guys something how many
teraflop could a teraflop clock this
entire clock
oh I like that let's just go with six
six and let's go with three hundred
twenty eight gigabytes repair with let's
go with that let's go with dropping eggs
back let's go 12 gigs around y'all
saying let's go with that nah gigs
around for gaming if it's really true
what they say I'm telling you right now
they did a thing and I'm very proud at
the end of the day you got up to Excel
BMX style well you've got the Tupac yo
good Tupac biggie I'm gonna give it to
me at the end of the day Oh get it Joe
any last shot out gentlemen oh just shut
up shout out to the whole FCC and I'm
not a competitive I do play fighting
games a lot I'm loving the justice too
right now but I can tell you this
Dragon Ball Z fighters will be in it
would save lock in my sister
I want to play it on the Xbox 1x I
already got a ps4 Pro but right now in
this anytime that 1x all day right all
day all day November 7th and that's my
birthday month so happy birthday to be
early let's go
there you have it rabid fans here at the
Xbox media presser look out for the new
hotness coming out and that is a wrap
for our day 1 coverage of Xbox one x two
check out a geek culture for more news
and coverage and live gameplay when we
hit the floor for more stuff